I don't know if you saw that rant I did
where they got really mad at me of
course I saw it I was my porn my my
sheets are ruined people were saying it
was because you were dewormed that it
changed you I know it's funny but like
that's not the first rant I've ever had
there's a video from our old Studio
where I'm like they went to this dude's
house in Wisconsin and were protesting
in front of his house they had set the
same protesters set fire to a house
before and when the guy brandished a
shotgun the police came and arrested him
from his own house and I was like these
people will come to your home they will
protest you these these activists
obviously and the police will kick in
your door and they will bash your teeth
in and then they're like dude but the
reason the left got mad was a reaction
to the right the right was like look at
this epic rant from Dimple he's like
saying that the lot federal law
enforcement went for James O'Keefe I
would I was surprised you know what's
really funny about this is when when
that with that rant the left came out
angry at me and I'm like I was literally
saying I literally abolished the police
I was like abolish the police like the
feds kicked in James O'Keefe stores his
federal law enforcement they leaked his
his privileged legal Communications this
is a violation of every core tenant this
country is supposed to believe in your
privileged access to legal assistance
and then the left was like haha he's bad
that's Fascism and I'm like I thought I
was agreeing with you I would ask a drew
a question Mr Constitution uh given what
you saw in Kenosha what is your
perspective on the police uh my
perspective is that the police are going
to have to start making some serious
decisions soon because if they're not
going to sign aside with their
constitutional Oaths
um they are literally betraying the
American people so I think when police
are getting into that type of territory
they're going to start enforcing a
police state so I think right now where
we are with the Advent of uh Marxism
cultural Marxism becoming mainstream I
think the excuse when police come out
and say I'm just doing my job is what
the Nazi said so I think right now uh
that is a crime against humanity and I
think when police aren't uh having the
will to say you know what I'm not going
to enforce this I'm going to continue to
do my job I think uh they're gonna have
to make that decision but if they do do
that if they decide not to and pull out
of it I think that uh that's something
they need to consider before they become
police officers because if you're going
to take a job like that you're going to
have to be prepared to make a decision
whether I'm going to obey
unconstitutional or illegal edicts or
mandates or I am going to uh resign just
another way I just got one quick
question given that all gun laws are
unconstitutional violate the Second
Amendment uh what do you think of police
officers that arrest people who have
guns uh that might be in violations that
can men who are otherwise peaceful
people repeat it one more time police
who enforce gun laws which are all
unconstitutional against peaceful
citizens what do you think of those
police and speak more into the mic your
audio is low low is my audio low yeah
yeah
I just think that police I think the
biggest issue right now with police
officers and I've talked to many of them
I've had conversations with them I think
a lot of them are really like illiterate
to the law itself not all of them but
every time you talk to one of them like
they're really not sure how they're
enforcing the law correctly like they're
not even aware of some of the laws
themselves and they're just completely
ignoring my question yeah uh gun laws
are all unconstitutional what do you
think of police officers who enforce gun
laws against peaceful citizens
I think the Second Amendment is for all
Americans right so what do you think
again for the third time what do you
think of police officers who enforce gun
laws against peaceful citizens I think
that's just something they're gonna have
to decide to do whether they're going to
do it or not well what do you think of
them that's what I think that they're
just gonna have to just gonna shrug your
shoulders decision so if a cop arrests
someone who has a handgun illegally
who's not hurting anybody or has some
kind of red flag thing what do you think
of that police officer who puts that
person in jail yeah I don't think that's
a good thing but what do you think about
individual the individual the individual
police officer yeah that's what I just
said yeah they're evil are they yeah but
you said that's not a good thing you
know me burning a cake is not a good
thing as well yeah the human being the
same is his name is the same question
over and over officer Johnson you're not
answering it let me also not all right
hold on let me let me phrase let me
phrase the question there was a woman I
tell the story all the time who was from
Pennsylvania with a legal gun and drove
into New Jersey and will give the cop a
name officer John Smith pulled her over
and he said you know your tail lights
out or whatever and she he said you have
a weapon on you said yes I do and he
says oh okay she politely informed him
but in New Jersey you can't have it so
he took her out he coughed her and they
tried putting her in prison for four
years how do you feel about John Smith
I mean I I would have to really take a
look at the entire situation okay I'm
not trying to avoid anything I just
don't want to say a lot of the decent
cops are leaving because of the backs
there's no decent box well I was just
gonna make a correction and say no I
probably thinks there are none but good
meaning cops a lot of them are leaving
right you're right that's true and I
disagree with Michael on that I think
there are decent cops but I understand
your point about the institution as a
whole but I I think there are I've I've
met cops who have been
that they've actually sought to like
stop violent criminals and rapists and
murderers no question and I've seen
these cops be like I'm not going to stop
some kid for you know this that or
otherwise I will also correct you you
said all gun laws are unconstitutional
yes what if the gun law was that you had
to have a gun uh that actually was the
case in America the colonial period And
I if you look it up I have an article in
The Observer that says must pack heat
arguing for using Obamacare as a
mechanism to mandate gun ownership
criminals aren't going to follow the
laws anyways
well no so we're talking about what uh
Michael had said all gun laws are
unconstitutional my question is what if
a gun law mandated you do own a gun like
that's unconstitutional it is
unconstitutional it's not
unconstitutional Switzerland makes you
do it that's a form of indentured
servitude owning a gun is of indentured
Services no if you make somebody own a
gun that's a disreservatory who are you
a servant who are you in servitude to to
who who's making me own a gun I thought
you're Anarchist I am an anarchist the
point being it's either if I disagree
with you about classifying something if
they made you join an anarchist
Collective to have a gun and you
willfully joined it as part of a member
this doesn't do the anarchism I don't
explain to me how mandating gun
ownership or mandating health insurance
is indenture servitude
I mean now you're forced binoculations
you didn't answer my question
insurance and an offer forced gun
ownership I'm I'm mad at you Michael I'm
just telling you I just don't understand
ex can you maybe this is my autism
speaking can you explain to me how
mandating someone owning a product is
indentured servitude as opposed to
unlawful uh
uh all I know is under my Common Sense
freedom and under what I want I don't
have to own a gun
circles let's not go in circles I think
he was just using the phrase incorrectly
oh okay okay I think I think the point
is like I I remember uh when when I
think it was Illinois mandated seat
belts I don't know when they exactly
mandated seat belts but I remember
having a conversation about do you have
the right to not wear a seatbelt well
not anymore you don't and then I had a
conversation from there about how you're
forced I remember when ObamaCare was
coming through and people were like what
about auto insurance the law the
government makes you buy auto insurance
no one cares about that and I was like
actually I I kind of do I you know I I
like I I of course would always want to
carry insurance but that's on a state
level as well the idea the government
would mandate you buy a private product
and and then regulate that product to
like guarantee now they use it as an
example oh You Gotta Buy insurance you
got to wear seatbelts you got to take a
shot I say I'm more of an anarchist than
malice I guess
oh first come sit in my life oh
oh you and Blair right listen you're no
Santa Claus I'm not sitting on that lap
so so we're playing who could Anarchist
out the anarchists buy books right
behind you yeah
I watch your show I watched him I know
you're an electron they're actually
genuinely smart respect you I'm just
saying I agree with Anarchist precepts
but informing that and injecting that
into the real world does not work I
disagree until it's scalable until it's
been proven it's complete anarchism is
in a location it's a relationship so
this show right now is an example of
anarchism there's a lot more anarchism
than we know centralization is when we
have government when we have fat cat
bureaucrat mafioso's coming in and
saying I want to cut of that it's
centralization decentralization is
anarchy decentralization exactly so I'm
so you're for your Anarchy and I'm
forever Nikki because that's the true
definition of it with no one intervening
no one forcing you to do something
that's the basic core concept
philosophies of Anarchy which should be
respected and talked about properly and
that's why I had to correct Joe Rogan
when he said there's those Anarchy no it
wasn't as a state-sponsored terrorism
Alex knows about that give me 30 seconds
I'll shut up for 10 minutes I promise I
don't believe that that is a lie that is
not true
I would like to give everybody
shut up
I actually
everybody in this room I know you all
and I really appreciate with the
producer to everybody and I this has
just been historic and Joe is so amazing
and all you guys and Tim thank you for
having me here you're right at Israel
Anarchy and it's beautiful and I love
you all and I appreciate being here my
my favorite thing I think all of this
was I was like we we end up we the show
started with us having Blair to come on
and then you know Alex was like I was
like maybe you all hijacked me we
hijacked it but the best part was the
very end when everyone's like have you
asked Joe and I'm like he's busy and
then Joe's like yeah yeah I could
probably come in where are y'all at and
I'm like we're in a trailer on the side
of the road yeah of course and so he's
like it's a very nice it's like it is
really really great and I just think
it's hilarious that you know was it you
said it like a step down or something
like the mighty have fallen oh yeah yeah
Joe Rogan coming from his massive
amazing new awesome Studio to my trailer
on the side of the road she loves you
too no I know you know he always loved
you but after you destroyed Twitter with
him he like puts you at the top tier you
know what's funny though that we had
beef
I didn't know that tell the story for
dinner
[Laughter]
so so
um it's not too complicated Joe uh
someone back in like during occupy era
somebody tweeted at Joe when his podcast
wasn't as big they were like you got to
have Tim pool in the show and then he
tweeted me like yeah for sure man why
don't you come and hang out and I said
cool so you know I was young and
bright-eyed and naive and I was kind of
like this is Joe Rogan this is back in
2011 money so not the biggest show in
the world you didn't come on my show but
but well I didn't know who you were
evaluated I'm Alex I remember telling
Luke hey get me get me get me Temple
well so check it out check it out so I
flew to LA and once I landed he messaged
me like bro I'm really sorry to do this
to you I can't have you on the show
something came up and I went
I just flew out to California and so I
made the best of it there's some
protests I covered a year later same
thing happened somebody tweets at Joe
like how come you never had Tim pool on
your show now it's 2012 and he was like
yo we tried to make it happen it didn't
happen Tim what do you say come on the
show and I was like let's do it this
time I was like I wanna I wanna make
sure we we confirm this like because he
gave me the details before I'm like give
me the details give me the time give me
everything and he does and then so I get
on the plane I paid for it myself
because I'm young and naive and I fly to
California and then he says bro I'm so
sorry to do this to you I can't have you
on oh my God some things come up and I
was just like all right now I'm really
mad and I was like dude are you kidding
me it's like a year later you did the
same thing and I thought to myself I was
like look I'm obviously mad about it but
Joe doesn't owe me any favors me going
on this show would be really great for
me so I was just like that's the story
and then what ended up happening I was
like I'm just not gonna I'm not gonna be
mad about it because he doesn't owe me
anything and I'm just gonna I'm gonna
focus on my thing I'm not gonna beg him
I'm not gonna ask him and I just want
about my business and then a couple
years later Joseph messaged me and he
was like bro I just want to let you know
like I am really sorry about you know
having canceled on you like that now
it's beautiful I don't want there to be
any beef or anything and I was like nah
dude there's no there's no salt there's
no beef like it was just like it
happened twice in in in Spanish but let
me tell you about Joe in the old days he
was doing so much comedy almost every
day and his other jobs he
we were gonna do his podcast forever and
he would cancel it too he just used to
like the podcast was a side thing and
then starting about six years ago he
made it to main tank and that's what
happened Blair I don't feel as bad now
because there was two times where Joe
invited me on and it didn't happen I
didn't fly out but um and then I just
checked my phone before I went on I have
a mess DM from him from two weeks ago
asking me to come on I'm like why am I
now it's my fault yeah he knew who you
were like oh hi Blair and I was like
well why aren't you on the show now
here's look here's the craziest thing
here's the crazy story you haven't seen
us taking acid in Vegas
can we hear about that story I would
love that you guys want to hear the
Twitter story because I don't gotta I I
want to hear the acid story over the
time
more and more than the Twitter story
I'll tell you a Joe Rogan story
well
can we is it is it is it is it something
where you're like maybe I shouldn't have
brought that up because it's a story I
probably shouldn't tell or are you gonna
announcement the big question is which
story should it be yeah the wild one the
crazy one so when you're you've seen the
movie like The Hangover yes this
happened before a few times I don't
remember when
we remember like
actually you get Joe on next time he'll
tell you but I mean I remember like two
days later because I was not a big you
know two days later like not knowing
where we'd been in like in Vegas with
him because he's like if you I went out
and saw some of the fights in Vegas
other places where Joey might get me
tickets he was a great guy and so I
remember like okay we're at ESPN and
we're on air and this is going on I'm in
a control room and Joe is whatever and
like two days later I'm like what what
happened he was like I'll see you later
I've been on a plane so it's pretty wild
man pretty well but Joe's not like that
now he but he's definitely done some
partying yeah I mean let me tell you
I've sat there with Joe
because now we go out he might drink
like two beers and you guys in great
shape everything but I remember like I
mean like like two days up with him he
wasn't on any trap of amphetamines it
was all just Joe's energy and we're like
drinking like 20 shots at like 4 a.m up
for two days and like taking Edibles and
all those I mean this dude's like a
thoroughbred I mean a thoroughbred man
that's why he takes the horse paste yeah
so no but Joey Diaz wants like we're
sitting there always like icky's eat
these Edibles and she was like haha we
just took acid and I don't remember two
days yeah
any Revelations any reality shattering
moments any kind of like Clarity in your
life it was fun except I remember and
this is to Joe's Credit this is like 15
years ago 60 17 years ago this big we're
in Vegas we're there two days before the
fight like a day after the fights were
there like four days
so two days before one day the five day
after and I just remember I'm like why
don't you take the the elevator to your
limo he loved his fan so much that I
remember like hallucinating on acid
while Joe signed thousands of autographs
because he's trying to go through the
casino once they start piling up and I
remember just like gay like like
hallucinating for like a day of him
signing off like like like it's like
it's crazy
there's like some cool story like naked
chicks that's not it's Joe yeah but
that's not cool that's not the cool
stuff the cool stuff is the depot taking
photos yeah selfies with people yeah and
signing autographs
yeah so I asked I asked Joe and I don't
I don't know if like I don't know if he
gave us like a robust answer he gave a
little bit you know from the from the
time I went on it we talked with Twitter
but even before that to where he is now
how his view has changed I think it's
fair to say you can see in Joe a big
change
so that that first interview he did with
Jack Dorsey was back in 2018 I guess he
was just like let Jack say yes they can
say whatever he wanted and then he got
heavily thumbs down for it we do our
show here we are today and he's saying
they're censoring it's coming from the
left and that's definitive he's seen it
I think there's two Factor there's two
things here for one like Joe really
started to understand and see what was
going on as things got worse but it's
also that things are getting worse
I want to make sure I preface that by
saying Freedom loving individuals
liberty-minded individuals are winning
many battles across the board but in the
censorship stuff as this becomes the new
corporate press it is getting worse and
I mean I think the reality is we're not
long for this world you know everyone's
like you know I see the comments like
wow Tim you really pulled this thing
together and I'm like yeah but there
will come a time the cliffs are eroding
and over time they are homogenizing what
YouTube is and they want it to be that
mainstream narrative Jimi Hendrix yeah
but but they know
the sand dumps in the semen but let me
just say this one thing because I don't
[ __ ] when it comes to things like
this
Tim was a turning point for Joe and I'm
not going to get our private phone calls
and things because Joe wanted to believe
in the system and wanted to believe
there were good guys bad guys and when
he he remember him I'm not gonna tell a
little story every caller he goes you
see whatever Templeton I said yeah I
heard about thank you I'm under attack
he goes well it's true Joe already had
all that understanding but as soon as so
it's true Tim that like you're like the
vampire that bit Joe Rogan no no no no
no no no I'm not just kissing your ass
that was the point I told you that
privately that was the problem but Tim
that Jack Dorsey moment was a corner
shed moment that shattered the reality
of a lot of people's understanding of
how things work online and you were
there you didn't fall for their traps
you went around their traps I was like
slapped up slapped them upside their
head and and then they're like they
didn't know what they were doing thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time